[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois pendant une heure
l'historien luc marie qui publie la
france en colère cinq cents ans de
rébellion qui ont fait notre histoire
le gène de la révolte est dans l'adn des
français nous dit il il y à des peuples
qu'ils ne se révoltent jamais d'autres
qui se révoltent tout le temps nous on a
renversé trois rois en un demi-siècle et
si on regarde les dix ans qui ont
précédé la prise de la bastille on ne
compte pas moins de 979 émeutes
toute l'histoire de notre pays depuis le
moyen-âge comme on va le voir est un
hymne à l'insurrection mais commençons
par une image symbolique de notre époque
l'image que vous avez choisi luc marie
c'est celle ci s'est éprise détruits
depuis le riz pourquoi la prise des
tuileries la prise des tuileries du 10
août 1792 parce que c'est elle qui
illustre le mieux la chute de l'ancien
régime à partir de 89 jusqu'en 92
whissell était encore au pouvoir c'était
un monarque constitutionnel à l'anglais
zh
hélas le disque 12 592 le peuple de
paris investit les tuileries louis saez
échappé de peu au lynchage
il doit se réfugier à l'assemblée pour
échapper à ses poursuivants et suite à
cela il est arrêté et conduit au temple
on en finisse une fois pour toutes avec
la royauté avec la dynastie des bourbons
enfin au moins pour 23 ans jusqu'au
rétablissement de la royauté avec louis
xviii
mais il est ensuite donc conduit autant
juger exécutés et on proclame un mois et
demi plus tard la république donc cette
prise des tuileries c'est pour moi la
véritable date de la révolution
ce 10 août 1792 dame le pion pourrais-je
dire au 14 juillet 1789
car il est symbolique d'une page qui se
tourne
le peuple de paris les sans culottes les
sections parisiennes
sous la direction de santerre donc
mettre fin à un millénaire de monarchie
française
dans votre livre luc marie que la france
est championne du monde
des soulèvements populaires vraiment
vous en êtes sûr c'est vraiment dans
notre adn c'est dans notre adn enfin
champions du monde elle n'est pas la
seule mais ce n'est pas le seul pays où
les où les gens les ouvriers les paysans
se sont insurgés contre l'ordre établi
ou pour réclamer plus de justice
mais la france incarne véritablement
l'esprit de révolte
l'esprit d'insoumission il n'existe pas
il s'est pas écoulé dix ans sans qu'il y
ait au moins une émeute une révolte un
soulèvement populaire
que ce soit sous l'ancien régime avant
la révolution il ya eu des révoltes
avant la révolution j'en ai même
dénombré 979 entre 1780 et 1789 et
virevolte après la révolution est
également sous la république et pas plus
tard qu il y a deux ans avec le gilet
jaune et gilet jaune en fait qui sont
les héritiers les héritiers des
croquants des bonnets rouges de louis
xiv ou des croquants 2013 ou encore même
déjà que du moyen âge c'est vrai que
donc c'est dans l'adn des français c
c'est vrai t'as blement dans l'adn des
français même si la révolution française
en elle-même et a une vocation
universelle avec la programmation des
droits de l'homme il ya deux révolutions
dans le monde d'ailleurs en une
révolution au qui ont ils vocation
universelle
la révolution française et la révolution
russe la révolution bolchévique qui
d'ailleurs à bout a influencé beaucoup
les mouvements populaires et les
insurrections du xxème siècle via son
cheval de troie en france à savoir le
parti communiste français
la caractéristique de la france quand
même c'est quand en un demi siècle on
renverse trois rois louis saez charles
10 louis philippe et c'est vrai que
quand on y pense 50 ans c'est la vie
d'un seul homme enfin un oui la même
personne peut avoir vécu trois
révolutions et je me dis ça doit être
assez unique dans l'histoire
ah ça c'est unique alors là trois rois
renversé en l'espace d'un demi siècle
après donc la prise des tuileries
justement puis ensuite la révolution de
1830 qui met fin à la restauration
avec charles 10 frères 2016 il voulait
revenir à l'ancien régime
hélas il n'en avait pas question pour
ceux qui en 1793 et ensuite à la suite
de charles 10 il ya la monarchie de
juillet qui est une espèce de monarchie
déguiser le oui 18 non lui philippe des
plus roi de france mais roi des français
toutefois il a confisqué la révolution
au prolétariat qui se soulèvent souvent
18 à plusieurs reprises notamment avec
les canuts à lyon et lui 18 et bien lui
aussi connaîtra le sort réservé à
charles 10 et à louis saez à savoir le
renversement de son régime
une application une suite en catimini
comme charles disent ils se réfugient en
angleterre en angleterre et pour
échapper évidemment à la charrette
vous avez dit louis xviii mais
évidemment il fallait entendre il
fallait entendre louis philippe bien
entendu alors revenons à la mère de tous
les soulèvements populaires d'après vous
luc marie c'est la grande jacquerie de
traits 148 alors voilà quelque chose
qu'on n'apprend pas tellement à l'école
ou en tout cas que la plupart d'entre
nous avons oublié qu est ce qui s'est
passé pendant là je grande jacquerie de
1848 celle que l'on voit juste derrière
moi qu'est ce qu'elle avait de
particulier
l'ajax riu et de 13 158
ah pardon oui alors là c'est nous sommes
pendant la guerre de cent ans
nous sommes deux ans après la bataille
de poitiers jean le bond est fait
prisonnier des anglais
les anglais réclame une forte rançon
donc il s'en suit une augmentation des
taxes des corvées de la dîme et caetera
et les paysans se révolte c'est une
c'est la première révolte anti fiscal
contre contre l'économie du fils mais
aussi contre les contre leur seigneur et
c'était d'ailleurs une révolte assez
atypique qui va être et qui se déroulent
dans la région parisienne dans le
beauvaisis
il dure très peu de temps seulement une
quinzaine de jours et qui se solde par
par l'exécution de tous les jacks à
savoir six mille paysans vont être
pendus haut et court à commencer par
jacques bonhomme leurs leaders mais ça
c'est une
c'est un événement assez uni
dans l'histoire médiévale car je
commence mon livre surtout avec les
révoltes sous la renaissance notamment
avec deux deux siècles après les jacks
les pitot ils tirent leur nom de parce
qu'on les appelait les pitoyables n'est
ce pas les pitot du de l'angoumois qui
se révoltent donc que celui sous henri 2
c'est un an après la mort de françois
1er qui a eu juste avant de mourir
l'outrecuidance pourrait-on dire de et
de promulguer les 10 de châtellerault en
15 141 qui impose et la gabelle
c'est à dire l'impôt sur le sel avait
des gens qui en est encore exemptés et à
ce propos d'ailleurs j'aimerais dire
quelque chose c'est que la gabelle c'est
l'or blanc dure de l'ancien régime mais
c'est aussi son principal talon
d'achille c'est à dire que toutes les
régions de france n'était pas soumise à
l'époque à la gabelle il y avait les
régions de petits gabelle de grandes
gabelle
il y avait aussi les régions de cars
bouillon et les régions france allait
comme la bretagne était complètement
exemptés de taxes d'ailleurs la bretagne
d'ailleurs qu'il appartenait au royaume
de france mexique 1 132 est justement
les paysans se soulève à plusieurs
reprises et sous henri deux îles sous
lui 13 et sous louis xiv pour protester
contre l'extension du régime de la
gabelle à ceux qui n'ont ils sont pas
encore soumis à ce régime
alors c'est l'impôt le plus vexatoire le
plus cynique et qui s'est soulevée par
le plus de perquisitions de 2
pourrait-on dire de massacres dans
l'histoire de france
et la gabelle c'est un impôt qui a connu
plusieurs morts hier qu'elle ait aboli
en 1789 elle était elle a été
ressuscitée par napoléon de nouveau
aboli sous la seconde république
ressusciter sous la troisième république
même la république a connu la gabelle et
il a fallu attendre 1945 et la
libération pour mettre fin à cet impôt
sur le sel c'est à vire alors qu'est ce
qui se passe et c'est que l'impôt depuis
la guerre de cent ans d'ailleurs est un
monopole de l'état 1 c'est l'état qui
contrôle le commerce le commerce du sel
sa fabrication
ils entreposent dans des greniers et les
fermiers généraux se doivent de contrôle
et de traquer les fausses les fonds
saunier enfin les gens qui fabriquent du
sel clandestinement
alors les gens se devait d'acheter du
sel dans les greniers de l'état à un
prix exorbitant
c'est tenter si bien que certains
préféraient le fabriquer eux mêmes et il
ya eu des révoltes parce qu'on envoyait
des commis avec des soldats traquer les
faux saulnier qui était en fait défendue
par la population
les curés qui sonnait le tocsin et même
les gentilshommes donc c'est toute une
population qui se braquer contre
l'économie du fisc et ce au nom de dieu
et au nom du roi et c'est là que
j'aimerais insister c'est que les
révoltes paysannes de l'ancien régime ne
sont pas des révoltes à caractère
révolutionnaire et on veut pas renverser
l'ancien régime ont fait la révolution
au nom du roi
on ne veut plus payer un nouvel impôt on
ne refuse pas d'impôts on refuse la peau
de la gabelle et on se dit le roi est
mal servi
les serviteurs ni fausse il faut que le
roi change de serviteur il va pas
connaître ce que font ces commis alors
le roi s'est distingué le juste le vrai
et ce sont pas d'ondés révolte ils sont
dirigés contre la monarchie
mais contre ses commis contre ses
serviteurs est bon donc bien des komi du
fils ont été exécutés suite à cela
donc qu'est ce qui se passait alors ça
se passait à plusieurs reprises avec les
pitots avec les croquants à cinq
reprises
so big 13 entre 15 entre 724 et ses 139
à cinq reprises les croquants ou mais on
les appelait ainsi parce que en fait
c'était discriminatoire mais les crocs
penser comme ça qu'ils appellent leur
noble vivement ça s'est retourné contre
eux qui croquait et la mède enfin bon
les croquants et ensuite il ya eu les
mains du pied au même moment les nu
pieds c'est à dire cette aide et des
sauniers qui marchait sans qui marchait
pieds nus sans sabots sur les sables du
mont saint michel et qui fabriquait du
sel à partir
il faisait bouillir lorsque les sables
pour en tirer le sel et le revendre
il revendait seulement un quart de leur
production au roi c'est ce qu'on
appelait le quart bouillon alors là
aussi louis xiii a voulu en finir avec
ce quart brouillon et demandé la
totalité de la production
alors ce qui se passe et que le peuple
lorsque les commits arrivée dans les
villages le peuple se réunissaient pour
défendre les faux saunier ainsi que le
curé et on réalise une armée de
souffrance
la population entière se réunissaient
pour traquer les commis et ont désigné
un colonel ont désigné un colonel qu'on
appelle le coronale qui était un peu le
gentilhomme du point et ça s'est passé
avec les pitots avec les croquants puis
avec les nu pieds mais même avec
les lustucru les lustucru sous louis xiv
donc les révoltes paysannes se sont pas
des rêves se sont pas des gens qui
veulent renverser la pyramide sociale se
sont véritablement c'est une révolte
conservatrice on peut parler de révolte
conservatrice et même d' économie morale
qui se posent à l'économie fiscale du
roi mais pas aux rois
mais luc marie ce sont des révoltes les
révoltes que vous décrivez là toutes ces
révoltes paysannes sous l'ancien régime
ce sont des révoltes qui n'ont pas de de
plan prémédité
il ya des armées de paysans qui se
soulève ils ont des leaders mais au fond
on a l'impression que rien n'a été
préparé et d'ailleurs dès qu'on va leur
envoyer annoncé l'armée royale elle est
bien plus puissante et elle valait
décimée à chaque fois à chaque fois
c'est un massacre a à chaque fois
ah ouais ça se soldent toujours par des
échecs les leaders sont exécutés
écartelé décapité parfois certains ont
pu fuir mais ça se soldent toujours par
des échecs parce que ils n'ont pas
d'armes
ils n'ont pas de canon ils n'ont pas eu
manque de discipline
ils ont des chefs improvisé qui ne sont
pas des chefs de guerre et donc l'armée
royale on vient facilement à bout ce
sont des révoltes qui dépassent rarement
un mois ou deux
à l'exception de la révolte des bonnets
rouges en bretagne en 575
mais sinon elles sont vouées à l'échec
cela étant le roi utilise à la fois la
carotte et le bâton pourrais-je dire
c'est à dire la répression mais aussi
l'amnistié
parce qu'il ne veut pas l'utilisent la
répression à titre d'exemple et de
l'amnesty parce qu'il ne veut pas non
plus s'aliéner toute la population est
donc la plupart des pour les nu pieds
par exemple beaucoup ont été envoyés aux
galères mais beaucoup d'entre eux aussi
ont été amnistiés la révolte des
lustucru voilà quelque chose qu'on
ignore totalement buisson les lustucru
alors le mont lustucru ça vient de
l'expression juste cru hein
est-ce que tu l'a cru lustucru et voilà
c'est mais ce sont des groupes en fait
des lustres que ce sont des croquants du
boulonnais
c'est donc dans la région c'est donc
dans le nord de la france en picardie et
en 762 bien louis xiv un désir de
centralisation fiscale il veut que de
l'argent rentre c'est pas par souci
d'égalité fiscale mais encore dirigeants
qui échappe à la gabelle et le
boulonnais depuis
la guerre de cent ans est exempt de
taxes de 10 mai et d'un certain nombre
d'impôts donc il faut mettre fin à ce
privilège
d'ailleurs encore une fois c'est quand
la royauté veut mettre fin aux
privilèges de telle ou telle région que
celle ci se soulève
1 et donc c'est pas par souci d qualitas
risme avec les autres donc le boulonnais
c'est 1 762 là sous l'impulsion d'un
certain mash up les lustucru vont se
révolter pendant une quinzaine de jours
mais là là c'était donc au tout début du
règne de louis xiv et c'était juste
après la fronde
donc il avait subi il avait suivi aussi
les pillages par les troupes parce que
la plupart des troupes se loger chez
l'habitant et là généralement aussi ces
révoltes interviennent pendant les
guerres ou juste après les guerres car
la guerre est synonyme de famine de
disette et de pillage et par exemple les
croquants souli 13 c'était pendant la
guerre franco espagnole la guerre de
trente ans et henry 2 c'était aussi
juste après les gars dit pendant le site
des guerres d'italie et louis xiv
son règne a été émaillée de guerre il ya
sans compter cette guerre civile qui
s'appelle la fronde avec la gare de
dévolution la guerre de hollande
et c'est pendant la guerre de hollande
d'ailleurs que les bretons se soulèvent
en 775 et ensuite il ya la guerre de la
ligue d'augsbourg qui elle va générer
les premières émeutes de la faim car les
premières émeutes de la faim c'est
vraiment sous le règne où on attaque les
boulangeries sous le règne de louis xiv
les émeutes véritablement de de la
misère et de la faim c'est pas avant la
fin du règne de louis xiv avançant un
tout petit peu vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure dans les dix années qui
précèdent de la prise de la bastille
vous avez dénombrés à peu près près de
révolte là aussi c'est la fin ce sont
les taxes on voit bien que ce fut une
période
on croit que la révolution française
arrive comme ça et que personne ne
s'était révoltée sous l'ancien régime
on s'aperçoit que c'est totalement faux
ça n'a jamais arrêté et après la prise
de la bastille l'été 89
ça va être dans toute la france qu'on
attaque des châteaux et et qu'on s'en
prend à l'aristocratie
ah oui non alors dans l'est dans la
décennie qui précède 2782 bon déjà il ya
des années de mauvaises récoltes aussi
le climat et mots qu'il ya une éruption
volcanique aussi qui va perturber
quelque peu le climat
un volcan islandais et puis à la guerre
il ya la guerre américaine aussi qui a
profondément grever les finances de la
france
et puis les tentatives de réforme aussi
de les différents ministres des finances
qui ont essayé d'imposer l'impôt aux
classes dit privilégier les ordres
privilégiés que sont la noblesse et du
clergé mais à côté de ça il ya beaucoup
d' émeutes des émeutes de la faim qui
émaillent cette cette décennie et
notamment juste un peu avant d'ailleurs
il ya aussi la guerre des farines et
quelques quelques semaines avant même
avant même la révolution avant même la
prise de la bastille la première émeutes
ouvrières parce que la rue sont ces
c'est une révolution bourgeoise et quand
c'est pas du tout c'est pas vous ne
révolution d'inspiration bolchévique et
bien la première émeute dans l'histoire
le premier cas insurrectionnel où des
ouvriers sont son parti dans la rue pour
réclamer des eaux la hausse des salaires
etc pour parler de salaire cette fois ci
les deux conditions de vie c'est en
avril c'est exactement les journées du
27 et 28 avril 1789 à paris près de la
bastille c'est la sphère réveillon et
réveillon c'est une entreprise de papier
peint ou le
où le patron de l'époque avait déclaré
que ces ouvriers étaient suffisamment
payés et cette phrase qu'ils étaient
suffisamment payés que leurs salaires
étaient trop élevées à a soulevé donc le
monde ouvrier
mais ça n'a duré que quarante huit
heures mais c'était déjà un prémice de
ski de ski à l'espace et au 19e siècle
au 19ème siècle cette fois ci les
émeutes ouvrières remplace se substitue
complètement aux émeutes e paysanne les
paysans qui ont encore une façon des
révoltés mais pas des révolutionnaires
hélas au 19e siècle là les émeutes sont
plus graves plus meurtrière et plus
longue
ce qu'on voit en lui luc marie ce qu'on
voit en lisant votre livre ses clés les
révoltes paysannes sous l'ancien régime
ne sont pas des révoltes politiques au
fond ça va devenir des révoltes
politiques à partir de 1789 ou là en
fait on a une révolte à la fois de
l'aristocratie contre le roi de la
bourgeoisie contre le roi des paysans
contre le roi et même des ouvriers vous
le dites juste avant là avec la sphère
réveillon mais c'est même le riz terre
oui c'est tout à fait minoritaire mais
au fond tout le monde à ce moment là
veux tu une révolte politique c'est la
bourgeoisie qui va l'emporter et c'est
contre la bourgeoisie ensuite que se
révolteront le prolétariat notamment
pendant tout le monde il devient les
1001 de son état sur evans de politique
voilà une aiguille du prolétariat c'est
c'est la bourgeoisie capitaliste
libérale
même si enfin au xixème siècle qui a eu
trois grandes révolutions prolétariennes
pourrait-on dire pour employer un
vocabulaire marxiste la première
révolution prolétarienne
elles ont toutes les trois échoué c'est
celle des canuts en 1831 même la double
révolte des canuts c'était à ses
ouvriers tisserand ces ouvriers de la
soie étaient au nombre de quarante mille
à lyon notamment sur des pentes de la
croix rousse qui se sont envolés à deux
reprises pour demander une hausse des
salaires est aussi à tarif minimum pour
la vente d étoffe donc c'était en
novembre 31 en avril 34 et la deux on a
on a dû envoyer l'armée à deux reprises
et à quand même eu une centaine de morts
c'est la première révolte d'étalement
prolétarienne ensuite une deuxième
révolte prolétarienne c'est celle des
ouvriers de 1848 1848 en juin 48 pas
celle de février qui voient ça c'est
louis philippe
mais trois mois plus tard parce qu'on a
aussi oublié la dimension sociale la
république sociale trois mois plus tard
ce sont les ouvriers qui se révoltent
suite à la fermeture des ateliers régime
les ateliers nationaux qui étaient
censés leur fournir du travail suite à
l'ouverture des ateliers nationaux à
paris des milliers de provinciaux ce
était monté à paris pour chercher du
travail n'en avaient pas trouvé et sa
efforts mais enfin ça constituer une
masse dangereuse pour pour le
gouvernement
donc les ouvriers se révoltent en juin
48 et là ils sont écrasés par les gardes
nationaux c'est à dire que c'est la
république écrasé ouvriers à partir de
juin 48 la république a divorcé du monde
ouvrier la république n'est plus l'allié
des ouvriers mais sont l'ennemi tout
comme la monarchie
il ya une cassure définitive en juin 48
entre le monde ouvrier et l'institution
républicaine
cette général cavaignac à l'époque qui
tue jusqu'à 1500 ouvriers je crois dans
dans paris en juin à oui oui c'est sans
compter le nombre de plusieurs milliers
d'ouvriers vont être déportés aussi en
nouvelle calédonie et est donc plus tard
donc il ya la révolte de 1871 mais qui a
intervient être dans un autre câble
c'est suite à la le peuple parisien a
connu une épreuve avant la commune de
paris c'est le siège de paris entre le
siège de paris qui a été terrible parce
que les parisiens ont souffert non
seulement des tirs prussiens mais aussi
de la fin 1
on a pratiquement exécuter tous les
chats les chiens et même chasser les
rats et les a battus les animaux du zoo
de vincennes pour survivre et
malheureusement ça aboutit à un échec
ses premières insurrections parisienne
cette première commune qui ne dit pas
son nom
du siège de paris qui a suivi la défaite
de napoléon iii devant les prussiens
parce qu'à ce moment là les prussiens
assiègent paris et donc après en janvier
et 71 l'armistice est conclu avec les
prussiens et quand la commune éclatant
mars 71 on célèbre cette année le 150e
anniversaire
eh bien les prussiens sont avec les
versailles et avec le gouvernement pour
assiéger de nouveaux paris et comment
comment cette commune
c'est quand le gouvernement deux tiers
veut récupérer les canons les canons de
montmartre
il était au nom de 227 ses canons
avaient fondu les parisiens pendant le
siège c'était une valeur sacrée pour eux
il fallait absolument pas que les
soldats récupère ses canons et
d'ailleurs quand les soldats sont venus
récupérer les canons la foule s'est
interposé et bien les soldats se sont
ralliés se sont ralliés à la population
les généraux ont été arrêtées et ça a
été d'ailleurs avec deux premières
exécutions et généraux le comté clément
thomas qu'on était même pas exécuté mais
lynché par la foule dit on et c'est
comme ça qu'a commencé la commune de
paris il se réfère d'ailleurs à 1793
parce que on va refondre le calendrier
on est de nouveau en l'an 79 de la
république
et alors jeudi un petit mot pour la
commune la commune et les pas
anticapitaliste la bourse n'a pas été
fermé l'argent n'a pas été abolie on
s'est pas attaqué au capitalisme la
commune les communards leurs trois
diables c'était la monarchie il voulait
plus entendre parler de monarchie où
l'empereur en finir une fois pour toutes
avec les empereurs ou les monarques les
militaires le militarisme
il combat ils ont aboli service
militaire ils ont aboli la peine de mort
ils ont même brûlé deux guillotine pour
montrer qu'ils abolissait la peine de
mort devant la statue de voltaire et le
troisième leur troisième pourrait-on vie
refrain c'est l'anti cléricalisme
et ça je voudrais insister là dessus
parce que l'anti cléricalisme
c'est une permanence aussi dans
l'histoire française on en veut pour
preuve pendant la commune ce qu'on va
ils vont exécuter l'archevêque de paris
monseigneur d'arbois et le calendrier
républicain c'est un calendrier anti
chrétiens on change on ne se réfère plus
hauts cris sa naissance du christ on se
réfère à 1792 nous sommes en 79 et ils
disent abad est prête à bas des
monarques mais on on ne dit pas on ne
veut pas remettre en question l'ordre
capitaliste encore vous allez on fait on
fait une pause et on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec l'historien
luc marie qui publie la france en colère
cinq cents ans de rébellion populaire
qui ont fait notre histoire aux éditions
buchet chastel
on en était à la commune dont on fête
150e anniversaire vous le vous l'avais
dit la commune c'est quand même une
guerre civile et on voit bien que depuis
le 19e siècle ya des guerres civiles
comme ça larvée mais on dirait qu'après
la commune
l'aristocratie et même la paysannerie
disparaît au profit au détriment 20 ans
au profit de la classe ouvrière
c'est la classe ouvrière qui va devenir
le fer de lance des révoltes populaires
et on al'impression klein stockera ci
est hors jeu et même les paysans qui
représentent pourtant la grande majorité
de la population active et encore pour
de nombreuses décennies
et pourtant on dirait qu'ils sont ils
sont plus là les paysans je disais oui
ce sont ce sont des révoltés se sont pas
des révolutionnaires lors leur fer de
lance enfin
leur credo c'est la liberté c'est la
liberté d'entreprendre
alors que pour les ouvriers à l'époque
le principal rêve c'était l'égalité
c'est pas le même le principe de
l'égalité qui qui pourrait-on dire
servait de cause commune à tous ces
soubresauts révolutionnaire
les paysans il va nous sommes nous
sommes dans un pays dominé par les
paysannes aïe ça n'empêche pas que les
révoltes se déroule dans les vides
on en veut pour preuve la révolution
bolchevique avec les thèmes à petrograd
c'est dans un pays essentiellement
dominée par la paysannerie la russie en
1917 c'est un pays est à 85% dominée par
la paysannerie
d'ailleurs des bolcheviks ont réussi
peut-être la révolution dans les villes
mais lénine comme staline n'a jamais pu
imposer le collectivisme dans les
campagnes 1
ça a été le gros échec de du stalinisme
et de léninisme alors en france à partir
de la commune de paris la commune de
paris si j'en parle aussi c'est que le
drapeau rouge la commune
c'était aussi la référence pour toutes
les révolutions ouvrière prolétarienne
de la fin du 19e et du 20e 1 l'énigme se
référer à la commune de paris et la
commune de paris étrangement
paradoxalement son modèle au 19e siècle
ce n'est pas la russie évidemment la
russie autocratique d'ezzahra c'était
les états unis comme quoi les temps
changent
pour eux la plus grande démocratie du
monde et des brassées ouvrière du monde
c'était les états unis en 1671 qui
n'avait à l'époque même pas un siècle
donc on 20e siècle
les mentalités changent les mentalités
changent et surtout en france avec la
naissance du parti communiste inféodés à
l'urss de staline par la suite le à 16
qui né en 1922 c'est parce que son
anniversaire et à partir de ce moment là
les révoltes en france ont toujours un
caractère disons de trahison ont dit oui
le parti communiste c'est le parti
d'étrangers ces parties qui est payé par
moscou
et il a les révoltes ouvrières vont
poindre un tout autre sens parce que
cette fois ci on veut renverser les
régimes on veut renverser l'ordre
capitaliste on veut renverser
on veut fonder une nouvelle société
fondée sur cette société dont rêvait
déjà blanchi et proudhon
c'est à dire mettre en avant l'égalité
totale
d'ailleurs gracchus babeuf sous la
révolution française disait à ce moment
là tous les to les ai tous des estomacs
sont égaux merci c'est cela donc à
partir de à partir du 20e siècle les les
ouvriers prennent la direction des
opérations et surtout surtout après la
seconde guerre mondiale où le parti
communiste a le vent en poupe parce que
la preuve la seconde guerre mondiale le
grand vainqueur de la seconde guerre
mondiale pour les masses populaires
c'est staline staline c'était un dieu
vivant
c'est la mère patrie du communisme et en
france on n'a pas dit pour 30% du
communisme en 1945 on frôle la guerre
civile c'est une espèce de guerre civile
froide une guerre civile larvée
mais pendant deux ou trois ans on est au
bord de la guerre civile en france
on en veut pour preuve les grèves
insurrectionnelles
de 47 et 48 qu'on commençait à marseille
puis à saint-etienne l'armée même c est
l'école et les crs se sont ralliés
quelque peu aux ouvriers et on a frôlé
véritablement la révolution si ce n'est
que staline a toujours dit à thorez
l'insurrection en france n'est pas pour
maintenant fait preuve de retenue dire
que le parti communiste accompagner les
révolutionnaires en 47 48
mais ne voulait pas encore
l'insurrection pourquoi parce que stan
il leur disait on n'est pas prêt on
n'est pas prêt à 47,48 pour quoi on
n'est pas prêt en 47 48
parce que il y avait en 47 48 en france
trois cent mille soldats américains et
staline c'est quand 47,48 la guerre
froide a éclaté la principale lutz et la
lutte contre l'impérialisme américain il
ne sait qu'il ne pouvait pas il ne peut
pas vaincre l'amérique en 47 48 parce
que seule l'amérique est détentrice à ce
moment-là de l'armé nucléaire
il faudra attendre 1949 pour que lui a
adressée à son tour l'arme atomique donc
staline ne veut pas de conflit avec les
états unis encore elie même de deux
grèves de grève insurrectionnelle en
france en 47 48 alors il a eu le bras de
thorez il faut s'arrêter un instant
parce qu'on a oublié complètement ce qui
s'était passé dans les années 47 48
les grèves de mineurs à une quelque
chose que vous rappelez dans votre livre
qui est complètement oublié c'était un
moment la cgt des militants de la cgt
font dérailler un train quand même et il
ya 20 morts
c'est cesser c'est pas rien on est un
moment où là où il ya des morts de part
et d'autre où la police tire sur la
foule
c'est la dernière fois qu'on a cassé ça
en france c'est la dernière fois qu'on a
connue des morts lors d'une insurrection
en france et bizarrement paris n'est pas
l'épicentre de cette révolution c'est
plutôt la province ça commence à
marseille avec une grève des tramways et
ça s'étend aux charbonnages
du nord-est ça dure un mois fin 47 et ça
reprend un an plus tard dans les
charbonnages aussi dans les mines
un an plus tard suite au décret lacoste
qui voulait punir l'absentéisme des
mineurs voilà et donc là il ya carrément
des batailles rangées entre policiers
entre crs est mineur et à saint-etienne
même il y a des coups de feu qui sont
donnés trois ouvriers trois grévistes
tombe et suite à cela on craint le pire
et en 47 ont fait même dérailler un
train le train paris paris pourquoi
paris tourcoing à la hauteur de darras
et d'ouvriers cgt d'ailleurs le maquis
communisme n'a jamais reconnu ça mais il
ya quand même une vingtaine de morts
dont un militaire au grade et il compte
parmi ses victimes et il faut savoir
aussi que à ce moment là au pouvoir en
france et le ce sont les socialistes
vous avez parlé de lacoste la côte qui
sera le résident du gouvernement
français en algérie au pire moment de la
guerre d'algérie sous guy mollet oui et
socialistes également le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est jules moch c'est lui
qui fait de tirer sur les ouvriers les
modes ailleurs qu'il va licencier tous
les crs il va licencier tous les crs
étaient qui avaient un peu trop de
sympathie vis-à-vis qui étaient issus
des milices patriotiques
il va carrément régénérer les rangs des
crs faire venir aussi des crs d'autres
régions de bretagne de normandie et à ce
moment là donc le parti communiste il
faut bien comprendre c'est que parti
communiste a participé au gouvernement
jusqu'au mois de mai 47
c'est à dire que le parti communiste
faisait partie du gouvernement mais en
même temps et critiquer ce gouvernement
tente et si bien que ramadier le 5 mai
47 les vire du gouvernement il y avait
cinq ministres communistes et suite à
cela ils sont rentrés dans évidemment
l'opposition active mais sans aller
jusqu'à vous voit il voulait
c'est-à-dire gêner le gouvernement mais
ne pas aller jusqu'à l'insurrection
populaire parce que encore une fois il
n'avait pas l'aval de moscou bon mais on
est quand même au bord de la guerre on
est au bord de la guerre civile il ya
trois millions de grévistes quand même
un oui trois millions de grévistes c'est
énorme surtout dans les bouches
rhône en alsace en lorraine et en
picardie ils sont surtout le sait pas
encore une grève générale
il n'y a pas encore de grève générale en
france pour trouver une grève générale
pour atteindre 68 alors justement on en
arrive à la cinquième république et sous
la vème république
bien sûr ces mai 68 c'est la grève
générale mais au fond qu'est ce qu'il y
à là en quoi est-ce que mai 68 est
différent de toutes les insurrections
qu'on a a connu depuis à peu près cinq
siècles en france
là tout à coup c'est encore moi j'ai
l'impression que tu de révolte marxiste
mai 68 à la fois parce que il ya le
parti communiste y est la cgt et puis
parce que les étudiants et même les
libertaires la plupart du temps quand
même un vocabulaire marxiste léniniste
il ya une espèce de sabir
révolutionnaire qui est qui est employé
à l'époque par toute une génération et
c'est intervient en période de pleine
croissance
pendant les trente glorieuses le chômage
est bas personne ne s'y attendait là
encore c'est une révolte spontanée
sap a été préparée de longue date et ce
sont les étudiants qui ont donné le coup
d'envoi de cette révolte c'est de
révolte départ et les chats pas la cgt
et les chats veaux parti communiste
d'ailleurs qui méprise souverainement
comme on dit c'est dre vote c'est une
révolte aussi de la civilisation et les
les étudiants ne sont pas marxiste
les étudiants sont plutôt anarchistes
sont des petits fils à papa qui déplaît
souverainement d'ailleurs aux ouvriers
cégétiste ils sont plutôt stalinien qui
veulent renverser l'ordre capitaliste
mais pour instaurer l'ordre s'alignant
les les où les étudiants de l'époque
n'était ni était aussi bien au style au
capitalisme au marxisme léninisme et
surtout mai 68 se déclenche sur fond de
la guerre du vietnam
1 ça c'est comme ça que ça a commencé
par une protestation ils ont brisé les
vitrines d'american express il ya des
étudiants qui ont été arrêtés ensuite ce
sont les étudiants de nanterre
hypothèses pour qu'on libère leurs
camarades
et puis à nanterre
les amphis les cours se passe mal on
finit par fermer l'université nanterre
et dans les rois se retrouve à la
sorbonne
là on commence à fermer la sorbonne
également et les premières rixe éclate
entre les policiers et les étudiants
mais pendant dix jours
ce n'est qu'une révolte étudiante et
c'est la première fois que les étudiants
se révoltent
il n'y a pas de précédent dans
l'histoire ou alors je vous ai parlé des
paysans etc
mais la selle on ne s'y attendait pas et
c'est seulement à partir du 13 mai après
plusieurs minutes varie tad que la cgt
ce rallye se rallier au mouvement en
profite
or on prend le train en marche la cgt
pour essayer de récupérer aussi la
révolution est là la grève générale
c'est la cave général les magasins les
stations essence et son service
les musées tout ferme il ya 10 millions
de grévistes
il ya 10 millions de grévistes est et on
ne sait pas où la france va nous sommes
de gaulle ça fait dix ans qu'il est au
pouvoir on lui dit et de gaulle la
situation lui échappe complètement
il ne sait pas comment parler parler au
gréviste paré à ses étudiants à la grève
ça commence avec le sud sud aviation je
crois mais est ensuite à révolte va
devenir politique
mitterrand on va essayer d'en récupérer
cette révolte un moment le 29 mai quand
où on croit que tout est fichu comme dit
pompidou parce que les ouvriers de
billancourt refuse les accords de
grenelle
c'est georges séguy se fait huer par les
ouvriers ainsi annoncé accor qui
pourtant annonce 35 % d'augmentation des
salaires
ils veulent la révolution rien d'autre
et là on se dit mais le régime est perdu
il ya eu 24 heures de flottement de
gaulle ou hésitent à faire intervenir
l'armée pendant 24 heures on ne sait
même pas où il est en fait quitte à
baden baden pour aller voir son copain
massue pour lui dire je ne sais plus
quoi faire dit moi ce qu'il faut faire
emma suva le requinquer il revient à
paris ou alors qu'on le croit mort enfin
bon il ya eu beaucoup de rumeurs là
dessus mais il revient à paris
prend la parole pour dire je dissous
l'assemblée et dans dans l'heure qui a
suivi un million gaulliste défile sur
les champs elysées c'est un peu de leur
de l'irrationnel tout ça parce qu on a
beaucoup parlé de mai 68 et au fond on a
beaucoup parlé aussi de la suite le
mouvement des gels et jaune mais on a un
peu oublié les émeutes dans les
banlieues en 2005 et or ça c'est un
moment très important entre mai 68 et
léger les jaunes c'est les banlieues en
2005 alors là voilà une insurrection
enfin une émeute on va dire mais enfin
certains disent une insurrection qui a
sa singularité elle aussi ah bah oui
parce que la cdm une révolte paysanne ni
une révolte ouvrière ni une révolte
étudiante elle n'est pas parisiennes ne
sont pas les grands pas nous les villes
ce sont les banlieues il pour la
première fois entre en ébullition suite
suite à la mort de deux adolescents qui
étaient poursuivis par des policiers qui
se sont réfugiés dans une centrale
électrique et qui ont été électrocutés
et suite à cela mais ça c'est pas la
première
en même temps c'est le premier mouvement
d'importance parce que ça ça gagner tout
et banlieue c'est un phénomène de
contagion et d'imitations aussi et ça a
duré trois semaines
c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de france mais il y
avait déjà eu des émeutes dans les
années 80 mais qui n'avait concerné
qu'une banlieue ou deux mais jamais
comme ça de propagation à l'échelle
nationale et c'est en cela qu'elle est
singulière et elle est singulière aussi
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de mort par la
suite
eh ben je parlais de mai 68 il ya pas
une mort en 68 suite aux bagarres aux
émeutes etc
ce sont les émeutes de 100 morts et même
je dirais même les émeut des îles et
jaune
il n'y a pas eu non plus de et il n'y a
pas eu de fusillade
comme dans un pays dirdiri ton
dictatorial mais la vème république
on peut dire a suggéré tout ces émeutes
la chapelle république n'est à l'origine
d'aucune de fado qu'un homicide
que ce soit en mai 68 en 2005 ou en 2018
mais justement aujourd'hui on a il reste
comme comme des fronts on parle souvent
de guerre civile en france on dit que
c'est une espèce de maladie nationale on
aurait la tentation en permanence de la
guerre civile et on voit bien que il y
aura un front avec les banlieues qui se
sont révoltés en 2005 il y aurait un
front avec les classes populaires
plus généralement qui se révoltent avec
les avec les gilet jaune les gilet jaune
qui arrivent là dessus pour vous vous le
voyez comment les gilet jaune
voilà là les gilet jaune d'ailleurs ils
n'ont pas de ils n'ont pas véritablement
de programme politique
ils sont bons ce sont des extrémistes de
gauche et de droite c'est la france des
campagnes pour une fois qui défie la
france des villes
mais ce sont aussi la france et la
france des pauvres qui défrise celle des
riches mais en même temps c'est pas
d'inspiration marxiste et la première
révolte post post guerre froide
pourrait-on dire
la première révolte populaires post
guerre froide mais en même temps les
banlieues ne se sont pas reconnus dans
le mouvement des jets les jaunes les
banlieues n'ont pas bougé lors de
mouvements des gilet jaune
c'est pour eux ils veulent sans qu'il y
ait aussi des extrémismes parce que les
parce que les la france périphérique
n'avait peut-être pas bougé pendant les
pendant les manifestations en banlieue
de 2005
et vous dites que ça n'est pas politique
mais il ya quand même très vite des
revendications en ce qui concerne la
démocratie directe
lerrick etc etc 13 oh oui ça va être
très présent pendant toute la révolte
des gilets jaunes qui dure quand même
quasiment un an
on ne parle pas que l'augmentation du
code les sens on parle politique
les prix de l'essence c'est vrai que ça
dévasté largement il partirait pas ils
voulaient aussi réinstaurer l'impôt sur
la fortune
et c'est quand même un mouvement anti
élitiste anti riches dans lequel
pourraient se reconnaître beaucoup de
textes communiste il est vrai mais en
même temps ils se reconnaissent dans
aucun parti et ils n'ont même pas de
leader sans sexe est atypique aussi
c'est la première fois qu'on voit une
révolte sans leader il était gamin qui
dès qu'ils dépassent la tête on lui
coupe la tête et mais c'est une révolte
si qui tue en veut beaucoup à la
personne même du président on a voulu sa
tête notamment lors de sa sortie la
daube y est le nom de la ville je peux
pas vous mais il ya une mais il a fait
une petite excursion dans un hôtel de
ville qui avait été incendié la part
parlé gilet jaune et et son cortège a
été poursuivi par des gilets jaunes et
macron c'est la pole pour mu pour la
première fois de la personnifier même
personnifié le la révolte on a il
fallait que sa tête tombe
absolument on a déjà pourtant fait qu'on
a déjà ça pendant mai 68 c'est très anti
gaulliste mai 68 en soliste mais pas à
ce point là là c'est beaucoup plus
personnel encore que c'est beau encore
beaucoup plus personnelle cancan 1068 le
trouve enfin toujours est il que oui y'a
un programme politique il ya un problème
politique mais il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de leader il n'y a pas de
vision à long terme et il n'y a pas de
véritable stratégie de changement de la
société on veut pas changer la société
on veut faire en sorte que les plus
démunis puissent vivre mieux
c'est une envie de vivre mieux mais
n'ont pas empêché il est non pas
renverser la vie sociale
vous dites enfin vous reprenez en
exergue de votre livre une phrase
célèbre que vous attribuez à andré
froissard mais je connais pas andré
froissard j'ai demandé qui avait 17 qui
avait dit cette phrase sais que les
français aiment la révolution mais ils
n'aiment pas le changement est au fond
c'est elle a l'air assez vrai 7 on aime
la révolution on n'aime pas le
changement
mais après tout on se dit que c'est
peut-être pas les mêmes
hausse parmi les français qui ceux qui
aiment la révolution et ceux qui
n'aiment pas le changement
ils sont peut-être aussi nombreux d'un
côté comme de l'autre ah oui ça là tout
à l'heure je parlais des révoltes
paysannes ce sont des gens qui justement
se sont révoltés contre le changement
mais il n'était pas révolutionnaire
c'est l'exemple typique que de français
qui se révolte pour protester des cas un
changement dès qu'on s'attaque à leurs
privilèges mais mais l'esprit de révolte
l'esprit d'un vote existe depuis cinq
siècles et je pense encore que si la
france existe dans cinq siècles il y
aura toujours des révoltés de toute
façon il y aura toujours des mécontents
1 c'est sylvain tesson qui disait la
france et un paradis où les gens se
croient en enfer qui résume assez enfin
où les gens se croient ou certaines
personnes se croient en enfer mais mais
il n'y a pas de meilleur régime
finalement un pays où on peut se
révolter en permanence c'est un pays où
la liberté on peut dire qu'il ya un
certain degré liberté on pourrait dire
aussi que l' on se révolte au passé
parce qu'on est vraiment heureux il ya
des pays qui ne sont jamais révolte et
cioran parlait de la roumanie qui était
son pays natal comme la pays où on ne
s'était jamais révolter et même dans les
rêves
au moment de la révolution de 89 contre
ceausescu où on a dit au fond c'est pas
une vraie révolution c'est une
révolution qui a été fait par
l'entourage de ceausescu pour se
débarrasser de ceausescu et oui mais il
ya peut-être des pays comme ça où on ne
se révoltent jamais et et nous on se
révolte tout le temps on se révolte ou
le temps devenait champion du monde
champion du monde des révoltes
on incarne surtout l'esprit dans les
votes en état d'esprit et même aux yeux
du monde on incarne l'esprit de révolte
la france quand vous partez en chine b
gt en corée du nord il ya deux ans qui a
un pays où on sait jamais révoltés parce
que ça a payé par lizac n'est ce pas
mais en chine
pour eux la france ça reste pays de la
révolution de la révolution les français
pour eux ce sont des gens qui ne se
laisse pas faire
je parle avec des chinois c'est etc
l'appli la liberté parce que c'est plus
on peut renverser un régime quand on
n'est pas content d'ailleurs c'est
c'était un peu l'image qu'avait les
états unis
auprès des français là dans la
constitution même américaine on peut
renverser un régime s'il ne fait pas le
bonheur du peuple
il est dit et la france la constitution
française de 1791 quelque peu inspirée
de la constitution américaine
nous sommes assez de cela ses proches
des etats-unis de ce côté là entre
parenthèses aussi ce sont deux pays qui
ne se sont jamais fait la guerre
etats unis et france on a failli cela
dit on est bon on a failli alors les
russes si les russes nous ressemblent
beaucoup les russes également mais eux
ils n'ont jamais connu là vraiment la
démocratie
bon c'est ça ou des semblant de
démocratie avant ils ont fait la
dictature de harris puis ensuite la
dictature la dictature rouge la
dictature votre cheville et communistes
et maintenant bon un régime autoritaire
mais pas encore tout à fait démocratique
mais qui quand même s'en rapproche
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
concluez en ce qui concerne la france
pour la suite c'est à dire que on voit
bien aujourd'hui on se demande
il ya toutes les occasions dé toutes les
j'allais pas dire les raisons mais il ya
toutes les occasions de se révolter
il ya la pandémie il ya la crise et que
de bic
on a l'impression que tout le monde peut
se révolter à tout instant mais c'est
imprévisible c'est que l'histoire les
mêmes les mêmes faits de ne jamais est
liée aux mêmes conséquences
je veux dire l'histoire n'est pas une
science exacte on veut pas savoir à
chaque fois qu'on prédit des rébellions
elles se font pas c'est qu'on ne s'y
attend pas que ça éclate les gilet jaune
personne ne s'y attendait fin 2010 8 mai
68 ça des ça éclate et aussi dans un
ciel complètement en bleu mais est à l
inverse la la france là ça fait
maintenant plus d'un an à moitié confiné
on annonce que les français
n'accepteront jamais tel ou tel autre
mesure de confinement et puis finalement
il accepte et et puis demain ça peut
enquêter
on ne peut pas savoir ça je de ce côté
là l'avenir est imprévisible
mais oui tout ce que je sais tout ce que
je sais c'est que il y en aura d'autres
on ne sait pas quand il y en aura
d'autres parce que ça fait partie de
notre adn de toute façon alors il faut
préciser que dans votre livre vous
intéresser aux révoltes aux
insurrections populaires
il ya des révoltes religieuse que vous
n'avez pas traités il ya les camisards
ya la vendée c'est un autre sujet pour
vous 1 ou le 6 février 34 qui est une
qui est une révolte elle aussi bas il
fallait choisir
il savait choisir oui oui mais aimé mais
je vous dis j'en ai des nombres on peut
approcher pts
approximativement parler de 10000 de
révolte émeutes et insurrection
populaire depuis 500 ans depuis la
révolte des pitot en france mais dans ce
livre évidemment il fallait bien faire
des choix
merci luc marie je rappelle le titre de
votre livre la france en colère cinq
cents ans de rébellion populaire qui ont
fait notre histoire c'est paru aux
éditions buchet chastel
merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]